good morning John it was the last video
of 2008 dust so happens that my final
area of 2009 falls on a song Wednesday I
wrote the lyrics to this song and then
sent it to the songwriting musical duo
rhettandlink and they wrote the music
and we recorded the song together which
was really freaking cool so I'm going to
go ahead and play the song for you and
then I will talk a little bit more after
the thingy hey do you remember when all
of Georgia fled that blood that left
thousands homeless and seven dead but
while those people drowned in their
houses been adrift the news of the ba
Kanye West and Taylor Swift Barret the
link where I really see the news media
failing us every time anyone mention
Sarah Palin a dispatch it up and camera
crews every touchy booze while I can't
escape the feeling she's just hot
and the flying favela killer got all of
detenida killing 4000 people while the
normal fluid mean until sixty thousand
people here and in here out people like
to have something to freak out about and
what about the Michael Phelps marijuana
scandal does one picture around the
media flew off the handle he did the
same thing as our three presidents I
don't think ivory or he's make mud sand
so many important days happened this
year friends
Iran's election and mass possession and
Obama sworn in but to us the things on
cable news seem so freaking dumb and we
can only hope that were not the only one
yes we can only hope that were not the
only one
and I don't think the crappy news
contender better than the scandals of
Tiger Woods and David Letterman it turns
out the rich guys cheat on their why is
that for the news in the year 25
and one of the biggest stories of the
whole entire year in that susan book is
he can bring an audience to tears with
all the pretty people auto-tune we
forgot you don't have to be hot to be
the talent Britton sky and I still laugh
every time I see something for bragging
probably holding up the sign for
clipping he's a tea bagger besides any
confusion about the resolution I think
no matter what they mean the news was an
illusion
so many important days have been this
your friend Iran selection and mass
possession and Obama's warning but to us
the things on cable news seem so
freaking dumb and we can only hope that
we're not the only one
yes we can only hope that we're not the
only one
and I think we can all agree the biggest
load of food that Balloon Boy Falcons
with not another little just another
year we kept the world alive we didn't
pay attention but somehow we didn't die
so many important days have been is your
friend pirate selection and mass
possession Obama's war in but to us the
needs of cable news seem so freaking
dumb then we can only hope that we're
not the only one
guess we can only hope that were not the
only one
but since they're still reporting it we
just might be the only one
[Music]
Happy New Year Hank and the other one
your brother I think his name is Don
John John
so that was written Lincoln this is me
and I am Telling You people if you have
not go check out their work youtube.com
slash rhett and Link there's a link in
the sidebar and if you want to thank
them for kicking ass and making my final
song Wednesday video freaking awesome go
ahead and subscribe and they also have
an album coming out on January 5th so
you might want to check that out too
John & nerdfighteria thank you for
making 2009 a really amazing year for us
all I could never have expected it to be
this great but maybe we can make 2010
even better dftba